hey everybody welcome to the final
scenario of park attacks
and just in time for halloween we have
haunted island
with the scenario zelgonia now according
to the description of this scenario
this is a mansion with a large
mountainous estate that is believed to
be haunted
and we need to purchase this land for a
very low price
kind of seems like a japanese uh housing
market trick here
i don't know if anybody knows but in
japan you can buy houses very cheaply if
they are believed to be
cursed in some way either because
somebody died there or
because something terrible happened and
usually
it ends up that foreigners buy these
houses for a cheap price because most
japanese believe them
it's be not really worth the risk of
dealing with
whatever supernatural might be occurring
there
and i guess we sort of have a theme park
equivalent of that going on here
the scenario goals are to have 500
guests in the park which is
not that many actually it's pretty easy
a happiness rating of at least 75
percent
which is also pretty easy there should
be somewhat of a caveat here and i think
it's actually that people
aren't too happy as they start off in
this park and then we also need to have
no loan debts
so seems like it's not too difficult of
a scenario
as far as the basic goals are con are
concerned but
then again we also do have a very
strange map and especially a very
difficult to work with terrain as you
can see the entrance is all the way over
here
and it leads into this big valley with
all kinds of random spooky stuff
fun facts and i know this is something
that some people have discovered about
this scenario as well
zalgonia is actually named after zalgo
which is an
old internet creepy pasta dude
it's a it's a face with the black eyes
and the black mouth and usually very
distorted
and if you look at the terrain textures
here it actually becomes a bit more
obvious if you look at it straight from
above but if you look at these terrain
textures you could see a sort of a
left and right eye socket here and a
mouth and it all just kind of
spins from the center and you have all
these crazy lines of
terrain painting here i have to say it's
also a little bit inspired by earthbound
i've been playing that on this nes and
it's great fun but also
kind of a spooky game but yeah sounds
like a good option
for a halloween special and i swear i
didn't plan this timing
but i'm pretty glad that things ended up
this way
so let's get started and see what we can
make of it
alright so the first thing i wanted to
do here is uh i'm
by the way i'm not going to talk like
this for the rest of the video actually
i
thought it would be cool for a halloween
special to keep it a bit more spooky but
yeah whatever it's uh it's algonia and
that's all that really matters the map
is spooky the rest of this
doesn't have to be i guess also i'm only
doing this as a halloween special
because it just happens to be timed that
way
i swear i wasn't you know delaying on
the whole series
just to end it on a high note but here
we are and i guess it works
anyway i wanted to start off by creating
a lake here because
as unusual and and nice as the landscape
is i guess it's definitely something
that's kind of hard to work with
i also thought it was something that's
very hard to make look good
so instead i wanted to try and turn this
thing into a lake
and have some yeah roller coaster go
over it
interact with the water as much as i can
so i'm going for an inverted coaster
because these things are
always amazing terrain coasters
i think the thing that makes them so
good at being terrain coasters is the
fact that you're below the track so if
you're close to the ground
you just feel it much more than if
you're sitting on top of the track
which i guess makes sense and i guess
that's why terrain
you know inverted coasters seem to be
much more intense than other terrain
coasters
take nemesis or black mamba i think
they're really fun right
anyway i can only do so much with this
terrain because we do have a giant lake
in the middle that i wanted to
have this coaster go over so that lift
hill is surprisingly
tall enough to actually go through a
full sized loop
and even have some speed left for some
other elements over the lakes that's
pretty good
so we get a bunch of inversions here
kind of the standard b
m deal except a slightly different
setting and i guess it's kind of a mix
in that way between a
traditional b m inverted coaster and
most of these terrain coasters for a
while i thought it might be possible to
also fly through the loop but that was
just way too difficult to make work so i
ended up making a corkscrew over the
earlier section of the layout
and then on the other side we go down
into another
kind of valley which i decided to also
just turn into a lake
something that really helps here is the
fact that you can actually recolor water
because without the dark
green texture of the water that i chose
here i don't think i would have turned
any of this into a lake
and then at the end here there's a
large flyover that's gonna fly past
what is going to be a part at some point
in the future at least i'm planning to
make it into that
not really sure yet how it's gonna work
out but in my mind it
works out eventually and then we go down
into the other lake and go through a
cobra roll which i figured would work
because that lake
is actually a lot lower than the earlier
lake is so with the speed that's left
you can
decently go through the cobra roll but
i'm honestly a little bit
surprised because when i was testing the
right while building
the coaster went through the cobra roll
with a decent speed but then as soon as
i started testing the ride proper and
opening it
it's going through the cobra roll at a
snail space and
i'm not really sure why that happened
but i'm gonna look into it at some point
in the future because
i'm not a fan of the fact that it looks
like it's getting stuck in the cobra
rule every time
and maybe at some point it might even
get stuck there
and that's something i want to avoid at
all costs
even though of course this game at least
works with block brakes so you can't get
the roller coaster tycoon crashes where
one train bumps into the other one
because
they can just let go of the lift hill
with the train still in front of it
but it's still annoying to run into
those kinds of issues
but yeah maybe i'll just make the cobra
roll smaller at some point in the future
we'll see meanwhile outside here the
rain is pouring down like crazy and the
sun is shining at the same time so i'm
very confused
recording this but i mean here in the
netherlands
autumn has actually been very spooky
it's just been raining and very dark for
the past couple of weeks which is
an insane transition from the very nice
late summer that we had
i don't mean to talk about the weather
but actually i do um
and now all of a sudden it's really cold
and dark and wet
so it's fitting for halloween season i
guess it'll be nice if this weather
continues until halloween definitely
feels like a proper
autumn not that i care much because i
don't have to go outside that much
because that's what life in 2020 is like
anyway to catch back up on what i was
building
i put down a haunted mansion here
because
what else can you build in a map like
this i'm very glad i had the foresight
to include this
this ride in the pre-given rides in this
scenario because if there's one right
that fits the scenario it's definitely
this one
and then of course also the the ghost
train
which i'm not sure if i'm gonna do
anything with that it's a fun ride but
it
does involve a lot of scenery and it
doesn't actually make that much money so
if i include it at all it's definitely
something for the latter half of the
scenario more for scenery purposes
but yeah that rides also in this
scenario for a while i was actually
thinking of just building a haunted
house on top of the hill and
make that sort of your pre-given ride in
this scenario
um but instead of going with that i just
built a haunted house myself
because it seems kind of more fun and it
still gives
players of the scenario a choice in
wherever they want to put their rights
and what they're going to be and it also
helps because the haunted house on top
of the hill is kind of in the middle of
nowhere
and guests in this game gets hired
pretty quickly
from walking up and down elevations so
that would be
supremely annoying from a gameplay
perspective
now for the coaster station i'm trying
something which i haven't really done
before
but which i really love and that is just
going all out with a
gothic theme it's not really a theme
it's really just
gothic architecture with flying
buttresses and all of that stuff
it's kind of like the building that i
made for hickory hills
which is a gothic baroque-ish fair
enough
but this one really has the the dark
flying buttresses
and everything that people usually
associate with
gothic architecture especially the
gothic architecture that you see in
horror films and games and all of that
kind of stuff
i didn't actually have any particular
inspirations
for this build sometimes i look up you
know some real life buildings and try to
get inspiration
from them but gothic chapels and
churches and cathedrals all have
standard enough architecture that it's
something to
easily base your stuff on i did take a
look at some
pictures of arkham asylum particularly
the lego
sets which sounds stupid but i always
find them a really fun way to see how
you can make certain themes happen with
very small and simple pieces because
everything in
parchitect is of course very stylized
and
looking at lego sets can be a nice
inspiration to see what you can do with
simple blocks to represent a certain
theme
um but there was nothing particular i i
drew from that
um so really this is just a random
gothic cathedral
i do have to give a shout out to robo
flamingo on the park tech discord
because i came across
their gothic stuff in architecture a
while ago and it looks
really cool i didn't draw too much from
it in terms of
color schemes or anything like that but
it made me realize that gothic
architecture is so much more doable in
this game than i thought
and it's all thanks to these basic
shapes you can
basically shape out anything with these
things if you
are creative enough in how to use them
and for these flying buttresses
i think a combination between the basic
shapes and the chimneys for the vertical
stacks and then using
the new diagonal basic shapes for the
connections between the buttresses
itself
it gives a decent idea of what gothic
ridiculous architecture is like
and of course at the front we have to
put a cross there as well because
you have to incorporate all of those
christian themes into your horror story
and that aside there's not really too
much to the building i ended up using
some fences
at the back of gates castle pieces
to try and make some gothic stained
glass-ish windows
i'm not sure if i'm a big fan of how it
looks but i
do think the texture works well enough
for it because it does kind of give a
stained glass idea obviously the colors
are
a little bit off um but what i could
figure i think it's one of the best
pieces to use for this kind of thing
especially because fences are
slightly to the right or the left on a
grit line
whereas walls are perfectly on a grit
line so if you're combining fences and
walls together
you can always make sure that the fence
is either set behind or in front of the
wall a little bit
so those combinations are often really
useful i think the same goes for
the stone wall fences it's always nice
to put those on the bottom
of buildings just outside the grid line
so that they stick out a little bit
to create foundations or if you raise
them up a little bit to create some
different decorations on walls i was
recently thinking that french
architecture houseman style might be
really cool to do in parkitect and i
haven't seen it that much but
i'm going way off topic here it's just
something that i think with all of these
pieces you could very easily do as well
now of course any church also needs a
big spire
so that's what we're going for here this
bell tower kind of
feels a little bit off compared to the
rest of the church building
not gonna lie it feels a bit more like a
train station bell tower
than a church for instance but as soon
as i started building it i was
questioning it but i was also like
eh it looks good i like it so i
just wanted to continue and go on with
it but very often
churches i find more than train stations
or city halls
don't have these extra floors on top of
it with a more open
bell tower or clock face structure
and instead just go straight to the
spire and focus on having a
lengthier pointier spire instead but
then again making lengthy and
pointy spires in the architect is very
difficult and even for this particular
spire i had to put
all kinds of roof pieces and pillars and
basic shapes and dormers
together to make it look like something
decent but i'm pretty happy with it
honestly and i still really enjoy
putting spires together
in this game one thing i noticed when i
was putting this foliage in here
is that you can now recolor all of the
planters in the game as well which is
really awesome they used to be stuck on
a single color and i really didn't
discover this because i didn't
really use any of them much in robopark
but you can completely recolor those now
as well so you can make the
bushes that used to be quite bright
green very dark green as well or red or
blue
whatever you want to do and for this
scenario that's particularly handy
because
well i didn't want to use any bright
foliage
either everything is going to be brown
or it's just going to be very dark
washed out desaturated green kind of
like the willows that you see
plop throughout the map as you open it
so
i'm just gonna go along with that theme
so it's good that i'll be able to
actually recolor all of the bushes to
go along with the foliage that's already
in the map as well
now at this point i ran my first test to
see if i could make money on this map
and uh i failed horribly and so
i figured let's just take out another
loan
and build another roller coaster and
hopefully by the time that this is done
i can actually make some profit now i
can already
predict because i am recording this
commentary just after i finish this time
lapse that it's not gonna go too well
but at the start of this video and at
the start of building all of this i was
still feeling very confident that this
scenario would be a walk in the park so
it's going to be a bit of a plot test uh
plot twist later on
but for the time being i thought it
would be a great idea to build this
powered coaster here
get a coaster in with slightly different
stats as the
inverted coaster something for the
people who want medium intense rides
and um also i don't use the powered
coaster too much so i figured it would
always be good to
have this coaster in here and make sure
that i don't just keep using the same
coaster types on every scenario
it's also a decently easy coaster to
build
i did want to see if i could make it
follow the terrain as much as possible
and
have a very curvy smooth flowing layout
but aside from that you don't have to
think about a lift hill
which makes everything a lot easier
because with most coasters of course you
have to worry about
what height you're on and whether you
still have enough energy to continue
into the curve or or hill that you're
building but with this one you can just
build wherever you want you just have to
keep in track uh keep in mind that um
the speed
has to be decent and usually it stays at
the same speed
at least that's how the powered coaster
works in game but i think realistically
you do want it to speed up
as you're entering lower sections in the
layout and to slow down as you're
entering the higher sections so i did
have some
varying speeds on this layout i think
it's top speed that it reaches
though is about 60 kilometers an hour
which is
pretty slow maybe i'll look into it and
see if i can
bump it up even though powered coasters
do tend to be pretty slow
because i think it's kind of boring but
for now i'm pretty happy with it
i also decided that uh the station would
probably be best
inspired by the station of the inverted
coaster
just a bit more simple and a bit smaller
actually it's not simpler at all in fact
it's
possibly even slightly more detailed as
i added some extra stuff
to all of the buttresses so yeah it's
just a smaller version that doesn't have
a
aspire because you have to be uh very
conservative
with wherever you put your spires i
think i mean
i joke of course and i always talk about
spires and weenies but
you really shouldn't place too many of
them i think and stick to places where
they are very visible and they're
clearly signposting that there's a big
ride or
a central building in a themed area
something like this and this coaster is
neither of those so i'm gonna use kind
of the same design language but
none of the extravagance of the station
for the invert
and also we have a small building that
you walk underneath
in the queue line but that's about it
the rest of the queue line is just
going up this hillside and at this point
i wasn't really realizing this but
people in this game do get really
annoyed at the fact that they have to
walk up and down and they get super
tired
so the fact that i built this q line in
such a way that you have to walk down
all the way down the hill and then walk
up again
is kind of mean even in a realistic
sense
but i just figured this would be the the
best
looking option at least the exit path
doesn't bring you back down again so
if you get out of the exit you stay at
the same level as the coaster station
itself is
and the station itself is nicely nested
at a level where i think the coaster can
just dive underground at the end of the
station
but as it comes out of the station it
can just fly
into the valley and fly straight over
the paths so
it's a nice kind of height location it's
at there
and finally i wanted to build a
gravitron
just because i had some money left and i
figured you know maybe this thing can
draw in some people and
make some money but a fat chance i
totally overestimated this thing
it's kind of useless but uh let's just
take a look at the map and see where we
stand
alright i suppose i have to eat my words
because i
just spent almost two hours trying to
get this scenario to actually work
and time and time again i just went
bankrupt and i had no idea what to do
if you look back into my financial
history you can see that on this attempt
which is
i don't know which attempt this is but
there have been quite a few i had a few
months of
ups and downs where every month you had
that
ominous warning that i would go bankrupt
and the park would be closed
after just one month of not making
profit
but then again i ended up making profit
again most of the time
if this month right here this 70 was
actually negative
i would have lost this this try again
and i had to
start from the beginning but in the last
couple months for some reason i've been
starting to make a profit again
and i can't put it down to any
particular strategy but on every attempt
i've tried to do a number of things
first of all keeping track of vandalism
make sure that
nothing ever gets vandalized and as soon
as it does put a mechanic on it
also of course keeping in mind that
trash cannot be anywhere and as soon as
i see that put a janitor on it
trying to see if the weather is not too
bad because one of the biggest problems
in this map is that the weather is
absolutely horrible and every time it
rains
people basically can't write the roller
coasters which are the main money makers
in this scenario i do have an indoor
haunted house but that thing barely
makes any money and the same goes for
the
gravitron here and then
it's also just really hard to attract
people in this scenario and it's
difficult to make them happy
right now i actually have good stats
finally
which i think is the main reason that
i'm finally starting to make a very
small profit
but for the longest time i had terrible
ratings and
it was very hard to pin it down on any
particular thing that's wrong with this
scenario
i have decent you know intense rides
especially with this invert coaster here
which honestly has really good stats
and the rest of the rides i think fill
in a roster of gentle to medium
intensity rides that should cover
everything
and then i also have food toilets and
drinks
the only thing i did on the on this
attempt that i haven't done before
is for a while i made drinks and food
free
right now i jacked up the prices a
little bit
to what they are in game without
changing anything
which seems to keep people happy but
before i did that on all of my attempts
the guest happiness was somewhere around
10 to 30 percent
absolutely horrible and people would
leave the park very soon
after entering if they entered at all
and i could never really get above 150
guests and we're now
somewhere around 160 so things are
slowly looking up but
at the same time i still continuously
have to
work on everything and make sure things
don't go wrong so at this point for
instance i have another vandalism attack
so it's time to look for the vandals and
kick them out of the park before they
destroy anything because my profit
margin right now is so slim
that i absolutely have to look out for
everything so
the way that i'm doing this is just turn
on b and
um by turn on b i mean just press the b
key so that all of the scenery
disappears
and just look through the crowds if you
see any backwards hats
funnily enough i realized that in
today's corona world vandals are the
only people who actually
oblige by wearing the mouth masks which
is kind of funny i guess they are
actually behaving better than most
people are but at the same time
they are also destroying everything this
scenario also made me realize that
people
vandalize things even if they aren't
strictly vandals so it's not just these
people with the bandanas that vandalize
stuff
they just do it way more than other
people but people in general will
destroy their environment if they get
mad and angry like
it's limb biscuit or something so i
don't know
it's it's something that uh you have to
be very wary of
i think that's everyone i could see for
the time being but i'll just skip
forward for a bit and
see if i can find anything else for now
i'm just gonna keep
slowly working up a very small profit
this way hopefully i can
still stick to it the next couple months
and then once
i have a little bit of income and some
expendable income
most importantly i'll see if i can spend
it on anything useful
because i'm also stuck with the money
that i have because i already have two
loans
so i need to repay one of these before i
take another loan which is also
kind of an oversight on my behalf i
think it's better to take a bigger loan
that you're not sure if you can pay for
it
because you might as well at that point
build some really big rides that can
rake in the cash
instead of playing it conservatively as
i did and getting stuck
on your map for over an hour either way
i'm gonna go back to tinkering with
everything looks like this month is
going to be
a hard one again and i think the weather
has a role to play there because as soon
as
this coaster isn't written by anyone i
don't make a profit
but yeah we'll see i'll see you guys
back in another time lapse hopefully and
otherwise
we'll see if how i can get myself out of
this situation
alright so that still took me a bunch of
tries
and also as you can see in the bottom
left corner two in-game years
to finally make a decent enough profit
where i feel like i can start building
stuff again
and make something out of this so as you
can see i
got a huge loan and that's really the
only strategy i have left at this point
i paid off my old one just so that i can
get an enormous new one
to try and build enough good enough
rides to
actually draw in more people into the
park and hopefully get a
an economy of increasing returns going
where
more people will write the existing
rides and i'll finally
start making some good money but i have
to say
this scenario is beating me up much more
than any scenario so far i wasn't
expecting this to be the most difficult
scenario for me
obviously i've made it so i'm not
entirely sure why i'm so surprised
it's just that many people have played
the game and i've tried to see
you know what people think of the
scenarios and what are things they like
and
dislike about it especially as i was
working on the scenarios for the new dlc
i say new dlc but the dlc that came
after
the full release of the game um but yeah
most people didn't seem to struggle with
salgonia as much as some other park for
instance
um adventure island i think was really
difficult for a lot of people i know for
me
also orchard acres was kind of annoying
but yeah i was i really wasn't expecting
this this scenario to be that hard but i
really think it's
it's kind of in the individual the
invisible difficulty of it the fact that
it's really hard to attract guests to
this park
it's hard to make them happy and then
the weather is just
absolute shite and i think one of the
things that made a difference
for me is that after a bunch of retries
i finally got some decent weather
which meant that i could make just
enough money for a couple of months
that i could get myself out of the
sticky situation
anyway let's catch back up to uh what
i'm actually doing here
i'm building a steel looping coaster
because it's just always a good coaster
to build
not too expensive always fun to build
something with and especially in a
setting like this i was kind of inspired
by
the new revolution in six places six
flags magic mountain
which is a real life swatch cop steel
looping coaster
which i absolutely adore and i think the
fun part about that layout
is that this the vertical loop is
somewhere in the middle of the layout
rather than at the beginning as it is
with many coasters but because it makes
use of the terrain
it manages to put it somewhere in the
middle of the layout it's also the first
roller coaster with a vertical loop
in the world ever built at least the
modern type there have been looping
coasters before but they usually
featured some kind of circular loop
and the new revolution is the first one
that did it with the
teardrop shape that we all know and love
today but yeah it's a really fun coaster
one of my faves in the park actually
i think it's kind of underrated just
because there are so many huge
and great coasters in that park um but
yeah
i just loved the layout and i figured i
could try something similar where i'm
hugging the terrain as much as possible
and you
start off the layout with a few curves
and swooping hills going over the
terrain
and then somewhere in the middle you get
that loop which
here is placed over the lake which i
think makes it pretty scenic
and then just a few more curves and
helixes and then you're back into the
station
i also didn't really know what to do
with the brake run station simulation um
section for this coaster so i'm just
putting it right next to the inverts
and i'm going to try to make some kind
of building out of that
not really sure how that's going to work
yet actually
i am because i recorded this time lapse
before of course and i'm talking
after the fact but you're going to see
it's it's going gonna be pretty
interesting
and the station itself is kind of placed
in an awkward position because it's
right
next to the brake run there so there are
gonna be two buildings very close to
each other
which i'm not a huge fan of from a
ground perspective it does look a bit
strange
but then again i do think it kind of
works with the fact that
most of the buildings in this area will
all be oriented in the same direction
all pointing towards the the entrance um
so i think it's gonna
create an interesting sort of gothic
dark town
look to this whole area kind of medieval
i'm honestly not really sure
what style exactly i'm going for here
but
just imagine an old 19th century
mansion that's kind of rotting away and
then just extrapolate all of the
materials and
looks from that and throw in some gothic
churchy architecture and i figured
i could call it a day so for this
building for instance i'm
trying something similar with the very
narrow lengthy profile of the whole
building
and then adding lots of detail and
brackets and
borders alongside the roof and
underneath that
we have space that could be maybe a
maintenance space
for the looping coaster i think it's
also interesting because it creates this
really cool
fly-through for the invert one of the
problems with the invert
for me at least has always been the fact
that it goes over that hill so
slowly and it just looks a bit weird
it's too stretched out and
strangely placed over the paths so
having it go through this building
rather than next to it i think manages
to mask that a little bit as well
and actually makes it a fun element of
the ride rather than
something that just looks kind of
strange i
maybe could have turned it into a mid
course break run
i guess is what you're thinking perhaps
but
i don't think that's something that
would work here because we still have
the cobra loop
after this and i think it's just too low
that the train won't be able to make the
cobra loop if it goes through this
mid-course brake run
and coasters should always be able to
make all of the elements past their
mid-course break run
if they're if they have to be stopped
for some reason so
i'm kind of screwed there and i didn't
want to remove the cobra loop especially
after i changed it into
the slightly smaller cobra roll sorry um
so yeah i'm just leaving this be as a
strange very slow
stretched out hill and
that's basically all i wanted to do for
that building now it's time to start
building on the station
as well which i
didn't really know what to do with it
exactly i ended up going for kind of a
second
empire main street ish building with a
monster roof which was not really
the first thing that i was thinking of
but and this is going to sound really
strange
i still had my google images tab open
with a few ideas that i didn't look back
on at all during the whole build
but i realized that i still had it open
with the arkham asylum lego set
and i thought it looks really cool and i
really wanted to build a building
much more directly inspired by that so
that's what this is
it's not really using the the shape or
exact details of that set
because i'm still trying to work with
the architect pieces and seeing what
would work best with parking pieces
but it is kind of that mansion-ish
19th century architecture so it's pretty
neat
i also decided to have all of these big
pillars made out of basic pieces
i really need to do that thing a little
bit more with different sizes and shapes
of basic pieces because the
possibilities with especially these
cubes and the fact that you can place
them anywhere on the grid that you want
the possibilities are basically endless
and i think the only
issue if you use them too much is that
it becomes a bit too time consuming
but especially for pillars like this or
cornices
or other building elements like that i
think they're really great for details
and that's one of the things that
personally i think i've improved a lot
on
um if you compare my first builds
for this whole scenario playthrough i
usually just stuck to the basic walls
and roofs and maybe some borders here
and there
some details but no basic shapes to
get out of my comfort zone and i think
the use of these basic shapes is
just one of the they just have so much
potential
same goes for that balustrade i still
love that balustrade it's so simple it's
just some
borders and pillar pieces between it and
then
some round and cone basic shapes to
shape out a balustrade and i think it
works especially given that everything
in parchitect is kind of simple
very low poly models and simple textures
i think it works to create balustrade or
other kind of classical details that you
want just out of basic shapes
and another thing that they work for
really well is
what you can notice on this building is
making pillars taper
down in in width as they go up which
gothic buildings like to do a lot for
example with their flying buttresses
and it just helps to add a sense of
verticality to a building and make it
seem larger than it really is
so this building has a lot of pillars or
blasters columns
and most of them kind of taper down as
you get to the top and especially the
spire
you can see it has some decorations on
it and stuff and it gets narrower as you
get to the top and then it finally fans
out again
and you get the big spire on top and i
think that just makes it look more
interesting than if the whole thing was
just a single pillar of a single width
um and no variation on it either so
that's just a little tip i would give i
guess is if you're building pillars
especially in a gothic style or
something like that even roman columns
typically taper off as you get to the
top and it's something that
you don't really notice all the times um
but
it's uh it's a little well it is forced
perspective
in a way as well greek and roman columns
for instance they taper down
a little bit to the top as well and if
you're standing in front of it and
you're looking up
you don't really notice that they get
narrower toward the top but it does make
the whole thing look
much taller because your eyes are of
course used to things getting narrower
as they get further away from you or
well higher up from you i guess
um and then we have a queue line where i
decided to be
a bit cheeky and use different textures
for the q path i don't know why i
don't do that more often because it can
work really well with scenery to have
some variations in your cues it's
something that you see in real life
theme parks and i guess
it's just kind of a leftover from my
rollercoaster tycoon habits that i'm
just kind of used to using the same
q path for an entire queue um but yeah
by all means just vary it up and add
different textures and stuffs for
different sections of a queue line
because it's
something that can make it look a bit
more interesting as well
and then over here we have this section
with food and drinks
which i really needed the happiness of
the people to be
at the highest level i could get it
because i think that was the biggest
problem
with my struggle of trying to get this
scenario to work it's difficult to
attract guests it's difficult to make
them happy
the weather in the scenario absolutely
sucks which unfortunately also affects
people's happiness i
think i'm not sure but no they just get
upset because they can't write any
rights
so i need to keep them happy no matter
what so
i'm just gonna have so many facilities
and janitors and mechanics walking
around
just to make sure that nothing ever
breaks down they can get food and drinks
wherever they want to
and we'll just treat them like kings
because otherwise it's just going to be
really annoying and leave negative
reviews
so yeah have that little food court over
there
and since it's next to the big church
building which is the station of the
invert
i figured it would fit to make a kind of
a mini version of that building
essentially
just take some colors and pieces from
that building and build a small chapel
with it
right next to it and then another
essential building of course
is a little toilet building here which
also has an information kiosk in it
i didn't even have an information kiosk
before i'm pretty sure
so that was kind of weird but the map is
small enough where i think people won't
get lost too much but
it's still good to add it of course so
adding that in here as well
plus it adds another building and i do
want to try as much as possible to give
this whole space a village like feel
so i think it works for that as well and
then finally
we're getting into my last section of
this scenario
the one last thing i wanted to do before
i try to actually make the goals is to
give this orbiter
a roof one of the things i actually
changed on my last playthrough which was
my final successful playthrough where i
managed to make a profit
is i just put a simple roof on top of
the on top of the orbiter
because it didn't have one of course and
it really made me notice
just how much of an effect putting roofs
on flat right has
so far i've mostly done it because i
like it aesthetically
many flat rides in real life will have a
roof on it and there are especially some
types of flat rides that i think you
should always put them on
like teacups for instance you see them
without roof structures but i much
prefer them with
but even from a gameplay perspective it
makes a huge difference and this is the
first scenario to make me realize that
just because it rains so often in this
scenario and i could see
all the time just how popular this ride
would become if it started to rain
um because this would regularly get huge
queues
and you could definitely notice that
people started turning away from other
rides
to go and write this thing instead so
that was really funny
um and it definitely made me realize
that perhaps
indoor coasters are also something i
should have invested more in
i know i haven't really built any of
them in all of my scenarios
with the few exceptions being
underground coasters which still feels a
little bit different than building a
coaster and then building a roof on top
of it
it's just that since you look at
everything from a top-down perspective
indoor coasters just don't work that
well because you don't see the coaster
and also you have to look
up to a big gray box probably
some kind of backstage building that you
want to hide
but if you're only looking from an
aerial perspective it's not the best
thing to have in your park so
i don't know i just don't really like it
aesthetically in my scenario play but
maybe it could make a big difference if
i ever come across another scenario
that's rainy
definitely need to keep in mind the
climate a lot more because the rain
absolutely
screwed me over so many times on this
playthrough
but yeah this building is just very
simple shape wise i'm still
trying to come up with new combinations
and variations of flat right roofs
this roof shape i think is something
i've done many times before but it's
kind of in the detailing i guess that
this one's different you can see the
pillars made out of basic shapes and
having their
capitals and bases and also a very fancy
fence on top of the whole structure as
well and then again because
i have a queue line with a small cover i
wanted to make sure that the cover
kind of has the same look and vibe as
the main roof
so i'm just copying the column structure
and
fence style over from the main building
into that little pavilion and that is
most of the buildings i think that i
wanted to build for this scenario done
there's just a lot of detail work still
left to do some
lighting as you can see uh which the
main which the rain very handily made me
realize
and well of course there's always a job
to do with putting clutter everywhere
and there were just some open spaces
where i still had to fit in some fences
i just don't want to leave the uh the
basic default fences anywhere so
i always try to replace them with my own
borders or
fences or whatever and of course
there's still a lot of foliage work to
do as well i kept the foliage
basically the same as you already get in
the map which i like to do just to make
sure that the foliage inside the park
boundaries
fits with the foliage outside the park
boundaries i feel like it would be weird
if it was completely different
but i do want to make the foliage quite
a bit denser
and i did add a few trees and bushes
that i don't have
outside of the park boundary so for me
at least it's always a balancing
act to see how much foliage i want and
how much more variation
i want then already comes with the
scenario
but again it took all of the willpower
in me
to not use the the new trees because
they look so good and i really just
wanted to
grab those things instead but i'm gonna
have to save that for
at the very least the uh taste of
adventure dlc scenarios
but yeah i forgot i still had two more
little buildings that i wanted to add
and these are these glass
covered buildings on the side of the uh
the queue line for the inverts these are
kind of inspired by
harry potter in universal where you also
have the greenhouse building
i know these things don't look like
greenhouses but that vibe
combined with the gothic architecture of
hogwarts was something that i always
liked
so kind of took a little bit of
inspiration from that
um but it's not anything direct i guess
and yeah that's basically all that i did
for this scenario
i'm finally just putting a bunch of
foliage everywhere
making sure that i have enough ground
shrubbery but
that aside it's time to run this park
and see if i can reach 500 guests
somehow so let's see
all right so i think i am about to reach
the goals of this scenario
but i'm kind of afraid that i'm gonna
have to hold them for a while
yeah there we go all right let's just
fast forward
and hope that i can actually make the
goal in time
um although i guess i have a better idea
while we're at it i'm just gonna ride
the coasters and assume that it's all
gonna be fine
so first of all i actually gave the
coasters a name
not entirely sure why but they're named
after
phobias as always because roller coaster
tycoon made me do it
and here we have the steel looping
coaster doing that kind of new
revolution thing
where it flies around these hills first
builds up some speed
and after just one more helix we fly
into the loop i think i kind of
misplaced that tree here
don't look at that um but yeah it's
pretty fun layout
and i really like how it fits into the
park i guess the only problem with it is
that it does take up a lot of space
on this side of the hill which means
that it's basically entirely useless
and well as it turned out space was a
struggle for this park in general but
altogether
i think it fits pretty neatly into this
map
and then of course we have the first
coaster
which i'm just gonna wait until this
train is done so that i can actually get
a proper look at it
so in the meantime let's actually get a
look at the station which i think
is uh probably my favorite building in
this map
um okay i'm gonna actually pause it for
a second
so the way that this works is really
just basic shapes
all the way down and i think you can
actually tell that i missed one okay no
never mind that's just
a diagonal one uh flying through it wait
that is a mistake
i don't have that over there wait a
second how does that work
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna try to fix
that just uh
just quickly doing some maintenance all
right um
uh right i see what's going wrong there
i
think i just have to offset that by
eight and then go into the middle here
and
then that should do it there we go
perfect
so yeah it's just basic shapes all the
way down and i'm just using the diagonal
ones
to make big diagonal beams for the
flying buttresses
and simple square cube pieces and
pyramid pieces for lack of a better name
wait that is what you call those things
to make the basic shape of a buttress
and then of course we have a kind of
fancy tower to
just stack all kinds of random objects
on top of each other
to make a unique spire and it works
every time
all right now let's finally write
zaugo's wrath
which is not really the the best name
for
an invert i guess i was about to call
this thing frightmare
but then i realized that i keep calling
inverted coasters frightmare
just because rollercoaster tycoon won um
i think it's one had one called it and
it's just too good of a name
but for this scenario and you know being
the main coaster
in this map i think it works to have it
like this as well
the start of the layout is obviously
very heavily inspired by nemesis
just a turnaround into a corkscrew
but after that it becomes a whole lot uh
well
less terrain based and we enter this
area where we fly over the water
into a vertical loop and then a quick
turnaround
into um a pretty kind of typical
well bunch of elements for a flying
coaster i guess
it's just that the order and the way
that it's placed in the scenery
is very unique there's a support there
which is kind of messed up
not sure why it does that and then we
fly through the
very slow building that also houses the
uh
brake run for the steel coaster and
finally into the cobra cobra roll i i
always keep calling these things cobra
loops
sorry about that one it is a cobra rule
um but yeah i made it a little bit
smaller
so that it maintains a decent speed
there's another tree that i have to
remove good thing that i'm doing this
quality testing
let me see let's get rid of that and
i think there was a tree over here too
yeah there we go the spooky trees don't
have a lot of clearance
which in some ways is a good thing
because it means that you can plot lots
of them together
and you can do a lot with them in terms
of scenery
on the other hand it's very easy to
place them through your coasters
which can sometimes be kind of a bad
thing
um but yeah here we have the final
coaster in the scenario which is
soggy because i couldn't come up with
the better names i figured
might as well just make it uh the kids
version of the big coaster
the park hopefully there's gonna be
a mechanic arriving at some points
okay three of them why is this mechanic
walking
okay tired fair enough all right then
we got somebody on the scene um so let's
give it a spin and see how it goes
obviously it's just a very simple layout
but at least
i figured i could make it a bit more
interesting than a typical powered
coaster
just by again making it conform to the
terrain
in some way and have some interaction
with the part work as well
i also tried to change the speed a
little bit which i think is a trick that
you can do in this game that
makes this coaster type work a little
bit better
because these things have a fixed speed
but you can change that speed for every
single track section so in this case i
made the higher up track sections a
little bit slower
than the lower track sections which is
something that tends to happen with
these things because even though they
are
powered they also do have gravity
affecting them
so i think it just makes it a little bit
more realistic if you decrease the speed
a little bit on the uh
the higher sections of the layout but
yeah all it really does
is just do some curves and
go inside for a final tunnel into the
station
normally i don't like to build too much
indoors but i think a tunnel like this
which is still pretty short
is doable and also i really couldn't
figure out what else to do with the
station because this is a very steep
hill
and it's kind of difficult to work
elements like that into a park layout
so just a few more things that i think
are worth showing off here we have the
building
for the steel coaster station and you
can really see those vertical elements
come back here with the pillars that are
kind of decreasing in size but really
the balustrades i think that's the
one thing that i'm taking with me from
this scenario to all of the scenarios
i'm doing in the future
really kind of love those things and
then of course
it starts to rain because what else is
it gonna do in this scenario
i did do a little bit of basic lighting
most of it is just on the paths
but i did hang some lights here and
there
and also some kind of spotlights on the
tower
it's very difficult to completely light
up buildings from a distance
but at least this is better than nothing
i figured
but yeah from this point onward i'm just
gonna skip forward because
i want to do nothing more than just to
finish the scenario and hopefully
i can actually do that because my guest
number is
dwindling for some reason i'm gonna have
to check if it's
maybe something to do with yeah i guess
so i need to
advertise the park again just to be on
the safe side i think
i'm just gonna do that for three months
but
yeah my my campaign just ended and i can
already tell that
the amount of guests in the park is
decreasing one thing
that i forgot to point out but i had to
do
off-camera and i don't mean this in a
ooh i just built off-camera youtuber
kind of way but i seriously had to do
some
strategizing there's a hidden entrance
in the station building here which leads
to an underground cavern
that uh includes all of this nonsense
um i always forget which button is which
okay
there we go we have two roller coasters
down here
one euro fighter which drops out of the
station
into a corkscrew and then goes into
vertical lift hill where
it cut it it cuts back into the station
literally and then also a launched steel
coaster
really weird the layouts don't really
make that much sense they're just
kind of semi-realistic i just had to add
these two coasters to reach the
minimum gas count of 500 because
otherwise it was just
completely undoable so yeah it's a shame
i had to resort to these kinds of
options i really didn't want to do it
but i also didn't want to mess with the
look of the scenario as it is on the
ground
and it kind of had the hidden benefits
of making me lots of profits because
whenever it started raining
obviously people could still write these
coasters so
it pretty evidently showed the uh
benefits of building underground in a
ridiculously
rainy scenario like this one
now if i'm correct i should be getting
this trophy and here we go
awesome um i don't know if you guys can
see it but i got achievement unlocked
the park attacked which i guess is one
of the coolest achievements you can get
in this game probably
um i even well managed to get one of the
challenge goals of course
but the other one it's year 13
which is probably one of the latest
i've ever finished the scenario even
though it's just 500 guests
this map is just difficult i seriously
underestimated this thing especially
with the weather
and how difficult it is to attract
guests and make them happy in the
scenario
there's a lot more to this map than this
seems to be on the surface
and it's not just a strange spooky look
to it
anyway let's go to the main menu
actually no i'm still gonna save it
and then we'll go to the main menu and
see if we get a trophy or any kind of
animation i actually have
no idea what happens at this point all
right
so we finished talgonia and we get the
big mansion at the top of the hill and
i guess that's it
yeah right yeah that's just it yeah
obviously we have the halloween map
right now because we're close to
halloween so everything's just a little
bit spooky but
we've we've completely done park attacks
it feels kind of weird i always end
these videos by saying all right
well the next scenario is this and this
and we'll go there next time
but i really don't know where to go next
time
um so in that case i should probably
reveal that of course i'm gonna continue
with these scenarios because we still
have the taste of adventure dlc
which is going to be interesting because
i've made all of the scenarios for that
one
and i know for a fact there are some
really difficult
but really interesting maps with really
cool settings in that
so we'll see how that goes on the top
left
there's the button change map which has
been here for the past couple of
scenarios i guess
and once you do that you go to the taste
of adventure maps
which starts off with this one
i i came up with the name for this but i
don't actually know how to pronounce
this but yukatan ridge
i'm sorry if i butchered this for any of
you latin americans out there
but yeah as you can see it looks quite a
bit different
we do still have something flying around
though so that's quite nice
but um yeah i'm gonna probably take a
small break
of parchitects i mean i say that but i
guess every
release of an episode between different
videos has been a break for this
but soon enough we'll be back with the
taste of adventure dlc for 10 more maps
and lots of scenario play now finally
while i'm at it
i just want to plug this real quick i've
never actually plugged this on any of my
videos but it has been hidden in the
video descriptions for a while
i also have a discord server i can't
promise that it's very alive or very
organized like many other discord
servers because to be honest i haven't
put that much time into it
but it's been online for a while and it
has many people that i've known for
years in it as well
and um i can't say there's that much of
a community but if there's a place where
you want to reach out to me
or chat to some really cool people from
the various communities that all kind of
overlap on my channel be it
parchitect or planet coast or city
skylines
follow the link in the description to
join the discord and
i'll see you there also of course follow
me on twitter though if you're
interested in all of my random life
updates
that's all i had to say for today i'll
see you in the next video
bye bye